[Music]
in times have changed news
gettin old you know you're so old here I
like the change
I'm 25 your time 24 oh that's sweet
young submitted by LA River it's not a
real River right you're actually
watering it now but it's not a river it
used to be and then they cemented it
there's water with floating pieces of
poop without ya and people but they're
trying to make it nice fine like being
like 20 20 try to make it really nice
but it still won't be a river no you're
trying to make it like Chicago and I
fill it up and then have grass and
people could have those paddleboard
things and then like go around and jog
on it we'll see people are concerned
about the way brands are interacting on
social media this concerns me like how
yeah what's the problem is like being
superhuman not superhuman but the how
they're being very human now like for
example sunny do you tweet it out I like
that I can't do this anymore
right during the Superbowl and so a lot
of people is he I mean is Sunny D like
suicidal or something what what does
that culper sauna fication
of like a brand adamite objects like
have a life and like there is that
what's called I do find any kind of
cream fun now it might be more cringy
but like for people to respond like that
is weird to me because it's like you
know like just interns run this [ __ ]
right yeah I guess they're saying
because back in the day brands were just
a brand right like they would have their
marketing it's like cool buy these
tissues and that's it like the tissues
now are like having feelings and I'm
cheering about the Hamburger Helper had
had a face true yeah you know the
Hamburger Helper man but they're getting
like political and stuff soon they are
Gillette or Nike and how they kept see
what's Nikes politics like he's always
has been politics really like what
always they sign company but they fired
Tiger Woods or they signed Kaepernick
after yeah oh yeah you did their whole
like 2018 stamp was real cover dick Oh
Little Debbie quoted Sunny D thing
they're talking to each other yeah
they're all
like people that is a little cooler
funny yeah yeah if you like something to
light was yesterday feel like giving up
here are some tips be realistic about
what you can do speak with loved ones
who will help break you from depression
tips like legit depression its Little
Debbie so I don't mind what Bart's
talking about if they're trying to be
like a persona and be like funny or
witty if like Sunny D is talking about
the Super Bowl haha hehe someone's gonna
laugh it's a little weird when you start
to be Tony Robbins as [ __ ] Little
Debbie and like let's talk about
self-aware that's like bro you tweaking
cupcake yeah I want your creepy feeling
I like their [ __ ] moon pie what do
they got it's like a pie account yeah
it's not a moon pie but they have it's
like a it's like a cinnamon cookie
that's a marshmallow in between that
sounds pretty - snickerdoodles yeah I
forgot the name of it it's like a moon
pie but it's not a mood bite size small
with the cream yes not the marshmallow
right it's just oh it's oh yeah I'm
having em forever you're actually kind
of nasty I had it again and it's like
really oily like it just tastes like a
chain they coat your mouth it does put
your mouth Isaac got them for his lunch
recently and I ate one cuz I love them
like that's how the star crunch tastes -
their oil is [ __ ] buddies and kids
aren't discussed and I heard they
changed the formula you're probably so
yeah so another example here was
pop-tarts responding to Sunny Deol Oh
God honey can I please offer you a hug
we are gonna get through this together
my friend that's [ __ ] [ __ ] so for
me isn't I like the whole
personification theme I think that's
[ __ ] cool but you gotta play your
character yes so if he's like if he had
like some my stupid plan of life I'm
gonna get my crumbs on you but then I
can picture the picture
yeah if it's like if your plate
don't you know your company your social
media [ __ ] mogul these guys these
guys a mogul yeah yeah but then you know
what all of us are compared to the
people that are running this account
they're just college grads with a social
media degree yeah they're all like that
have no [ __ ] experience actually
building [ __ ] on their own they get
hired into these companies and then they
pull [ __ ] do you think it's young people
like that because I know I'm the only
big company that I can speak for is
Reeboks I've worked with him for a
couple runs of rebus I like an OG like
this dudes like probably like a 50 year
old see like 40 I like 40 and he's done
it for a long time and maybe he doesn't
type it in but he's running the squad
that will campaign the big campaign but
we're talking about the 18 year olds
that are the squad that are actually
doing the 18 year olds are like probably
like the streets like the street team
like making sure that they like comment
and forums and [ __ ] because I I did [ __ ]
like that for my marketing internship I
do agree with Barton there was something
recently I can't think of it but they
are like witty and kinda jack-in-the-box
I think is pretty funny with that Taco
Bell did something recently I think that
was funny Burger King and all of them
are all like people like I don't mind
yeah I think it was Burger King and
someone else came out of like fired up
maybe Wendy's or yeah the whopper I
think they had like a similar burger or
something like I think it's just funny
another one was like an influencer or
something a mogul a mogul no I think
this guy was like a twitch streamer and
he said something like five years ago
about like Taco Bell sponsoring them and
they like went back and found it and
like ripped them for it or something
like you're like in a friendly way you
know but as the main Taco Bell account
like I think that's funny yes for me it
did just it's cool if they speak from
that character's perspective that's
Brandon based and there's Brandon and
they stay consistent to it but they say
like random Shelly hey did you know the
eggs are only 89 cents it's like what
the [ __ ] why is tires telling me about
this eggs it's kind of weird to me that
they're interacting with other companies
that are similar to them really trying
to be friends yeah I wonder if they're
owned by a bigger company that's the
same you know like
Procter & Gamble owns like everything
yeah like maybe Nestle owns all these
and so they're [ __ ] they're all
friends it might be like yeah Taco Bell
and Pizza Hut they're all open but
they're all by the same group right or
like Chipotle McDonald's or similar
groups yeah oh no no I think McDonald's
had a lot of shares in chapala yeah
something like that
that makes sense was still kind of weird
it's kind of weird to Little Debbie to
be talking to Sunny D yeah it's like
dark have a serious are people against
this or are just people like weirded out
by it it's like they're weirded out
because just pointing out like the
difference in like how brands are
behaving oh I mean it's good or bad but
it's just like Oh take like take notice
like yeah kind of weird and like if
you're a brand should you be doing this
to together notice yeah underlying thing
here is that they're not sticking to
their branding they're not being
consistent with their branding with
Bart's example of like why is Goodyear
tires telling me about how to cook eight
that's true cuz when McDonald's tweet I
wish it was ronald himself yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's been kind of missing
you already go where's the Hamburglar he
died like in the 80s bro and that like
for real died like he just did but like
I went I went to hamburger University I
went to McDonald's headquarters and
Ronald was nowhere to be found
he's retired dude is unnecessary now I
want they still use him for the charity
stuff maybe he's working on their
nonprofit or some [ __ ] but I was hoping
that he was the CEO he's making the
business moves alright I thought he was
gonna come down and shake my hand with
the striped Red Sox guy that [ __ ] scary
and then Hamburglar was gonna come down
and grim it tonight but I imagine him at
night yeah who's a vampire looking one
Hamburglar no I thought the Hamburglar
is the purple one that's grimace all
right whoopsy and in the girl the she
was like a bird with it with the
pigtails I was picturing the
chuck-e-cheese bird
oh [ __ ] maybe that's what I picture him
in that three little like like pom pom
balls that are
yeah well that's marketing I mean I like
them but I there were no where to be
found
it was all these people in business
suits and [ __ ] and all it's just like
you're so disappointed I wonder what the
statistics are for some of these
companies if marketing is working this
way yeah so there's this one company
called stay come and they sell like
frozen patties and stuff like beef and
they're marketing they have a marketing
person that's like very first person
singular perspective and they have seen
an increase in their sales but what are
some of their their tweets yep they're
more on brand yeah they're probably way
more aligned in their branding yeah so
here's one this was actually a really
long thread this is the first tweet in
this thread it says why are so many
young people flocking to brands on
social media for love guidance and
attention well that's good they're
isolated from real communities working
service jobs they hate while barely
making ends meet
and are living with unchecked personal
slash mental health problems that's
still a little deep what kind of company
is this frozen patties yeah I wouldn't
follow them yeah that's a little too DS
to me I like brands because they have
their own world and if the minute I
enter their world and it's too like mine
it's too real are you my therapist yeah
what the [ __ ] on my knives is weird like
I use your burger to escape let me let
me [ __ ] get that two minutes of
escape yeah if it was like national like
suicide awareness that's know I'm like
oh that's very fitting now you're giving
back to your community cool I still
don't even want to listen to that [ __ ]
if I follow like Fiji water right every
post and tweet and commish and make me
feel like but if it doesn't if I read it
yeah and it's like you have bunions on
your feet I'm like what the [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] am i following you near my bunion
advice but then they go let's drink more
water but if it leaves me in a way like
okay cool we also they're saying like
you know they've gotten DMS they come
has gotten DMS from people like seeking
advice about like real life [ __ ]
it's kids you know there's like 12 year
olds and then they're like oh stay comes
is funny like maybe innocent adult maybe
I can ask Bagel Bites what should I do
they're asking for it though when they
tweet out about mental health if they've
treated about mental health you're
asking someone says something smart
you're like oh they must know something
cool by megabytes or [ __ ] good doctor
souls my shoulder hurt ankle bites is my
dick big enough
that shit's crazy yes professor the
University of Chicago professor said in
a summary saying quote it can't say
anything good about society when
depressed people feel their best outlet
is the Twitter account first Ingham yeah
that's [ __ ] big brands and
traditional like old school companies
are starting to catch up to the rest of
the world I agree advertising and
marketing has been evolving in online
like that's just where the major plays
are gonna be happening and they're
finally getting into it and I think
that's them trying to work it out like
it's almost like an old person on
Facebook you know our old person just
with social medias they're so [ __ ]
weird with it I think that's kind of
what we're witnessing right now oh I saw
bark wanna talk about his mental health
because he had a bad day I'm gonna do
that like no shut up Reese's Pieces
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]